if you just grab your two high school or
your boxer two days message is for you I
want to tell you about ten things I wish
I knew when I graduated high school
number one your parents will generally
give it a say for advice they're
struggling with you go from being a baby
living at home to go on and become an
adult that's tougher them go make your
own mistake just don't make the big ones
number two I mean some some men normally
I just go out with the dominant B today
know much more your cooing always tear
your condom because if you get in heat
at the moment you ain't got a condom you
may find yourself saying yeah number
three most of your current best friends
in the world will just be acquaintances
in no time number four get off your
athletes just mad mad mad mad mad some
teachers have no clue what the hell
they're talking about even the ones that
look very smart number five Bernie
Sanders may be cool right now but
socialism and communism just doesn't
work number six don't waste mommy and
daddy's money on useless degrees like
fine arts and philosophy number seven if
someone hasn't broken your heart yet
they will what's going to be all right
I'm actually be a good thing for you
where are my chances nothing number
eight your metabolism will eventually
get the best of you so all this pizza
ice cream you can get away with today
and I'm gonna be like that forever well
how many thirty and forty year olds have
love handles they used to look at at one
point number nine if you're still a
virgin I mean that's just between us
you're not the only virgin on the planet
just don't keep the two you're 40 they
may make a movie about you are you a
virgin are you a virgin yeah yeah like
not since I was 10 number 10
life is very expensive don't let a
boyfriend girlfriend teacher anybody
fool you that money doesn't matter money
matters mortgage payments expensive kids
are expensive marriage is expensive
everything is expensive go make your
money
having said all of that you watching
this that just graduated from high
school you're generally going to make
one of five choices one you're going to
go to college
two you're going to go get a job three
you're going to go become a soldier join
the military
four you'll start a business and five
you'll do nothing but what I could tell
you no matter which one of those five
things you'll choose here's what you got
to be thinking about the sooner you get
clear on what you want out of life you
will have an edge which means who you
want to marry how you want to marry what
career you want what do you want to live
the sooner you get clear on that the
more edge you'll have over everybody
else and last but not least I'm gonna
tell you what I'm gonna tell my kids for
years leave anything you do in any
situation you're in leave the people
that around you to improve daily three
respect people even though once you
disagree with for love people love
people don't bully people and don't get
bullied and eventually good things will
end up happening to you so with that
being tell us and congratulations on
graduating from high school and go live
a great life
[Music]
you